chris sims
final day of the work week it's friday
for him it's thursday for everyone else
and i don't think there are any days off
for our next guest there is no weekend
every weekend you'll see him doing
something on nbc he can do it all you
know i'm reminded of the phrase jack of
all trades master of none this guy is
jack of all trades master of all
fair i think i think he's kind of
fair he doesn't really attack his job
that toughness yeah he's mike to rico he
joins us now what's up mike
hello mike well you know for those who
can't hit the mute button which is scary
uh yeah for those for those of us like
me and you gloria who work five day
weeks
it's uh nice to be with you on a
thursday
very nicely done very nice
uh so uh mike there's a lot going on in
the nfl there's always something going
on in the nfl what was your thought
yesterday when you saw that mike
mckagman is out as the gm nearly three
weeks after the draft
yeah so i grew up a jets fan i grew up
in queens uh going to games at old chase
stadium
and i i've kind of grown out of my uh
fandom at this point i think for
professional reasons and
for my sanity too as a jazz fan growing
up it's it's just it's typical jets now
i do think it is a good point that uh
chris just made on the radio side
the the league year is over so if you're
going to make a change in the front
office this is the best time to uh even
though it feels like it should be
something that happens at the end of the
season but then at the end of the season
that is the prime time for
all your
off-season moves free agency draft
scouts etc so it makes sense there uh
look if they if they say adam gates is
all in and he's the guy and he's gonna
be the the king sitting on top of the
throne here that that is fine and you
want to go this way that's okay it's
just interesting that this was not their
first head coaching choice and now a few
months later he's in charge of the whole
deal yeah i mean uh all right so i
wanted to switch gears a little bit and
get off the jets are we okay with that
guys are we allowed to get off because
you complained last hour we didn't have
more time to talk about the jets and now
you want to pivot away after one
question go ahead well i i was just
because i said i have to deal with four
days a week mike no well i'm interested
in the fact that mike got to talk to
baker mayfield you know a few weeks ago
at the kentucky derby i just want to
know the guy that's followed the nfl so
much over the years and everything have
you ever seen a lightning rod type
quarterback or anybody you can compare
baker mayfield to what he's done in an
organization anybody jump out to you
not not right away not jump in and no
back down don't be afraid of taking on
challenges making bold pronouncements uh
etc but
i kind of like it and i think it fits
cleveland because it's
it gets them out of the mode of same old
browns so there are parts of it i really
like
also i i just
i just put the pause button on a little
bit with the browns there's so much
excitement i went through uh cleveland
went through columbus a couple different
times in the last two months
there's so much excitement about the
browns and you take a look back baker
mayfield was six and seven as a starting
quarterback so it's not as though they
won nine ten games they did do very well
down the stretch last year in some key
spots
we have to remember new defensive
coordinator freddie kitchen's first time
head coach he wasn't even the offensive
coordinator week one last year right now
we fast forward him in four months to
head coach and as we all know there are
mistakes you make the first time around
the block doing a job so there may be
some bumps along the road here i do like
everything they've done including
bringing in odell if there's a place
odell is going to fit here it's having
jarvis land here i think those two guys
together
could be a dynamic force of let's know
almost it reminds me a little bit guys
of what we see in the nba where super
friends are uniting to take on the world
i i do think you're going to get the
best out of them because of the
combination the question does become
have they put themselves too far out
there can they back off and just do it
on the field and early they're going to
be in a couple of spots guys they
haven't been in a while they have a
monday night game they followed up with
sunday night against the rams so by week
three we're going to know if they're
ready for their close-up or not and mike
the bar is so high for a team that had
won one game in two total years
2016-2017
i asked chris this question last hour
and i'm going to ask you what does it
take in your mind for the browns to meet
the expectations that we all seem to
have for them how far do they have to go
to january or into january to get to the
point where yeah they had a successful
year all right you're gonna think i'm
stupid i think nine and seven
and uh be in the mix for the wild card
be be not in the hunts be one of those
teams in that middle panel of the three
yeah that we look at
we put up that graphic of the playoff
chase the last few weeks be one of those
teams that's either sixth or seventh and
fighting to get in that last spot or a
wild card spot as a minimum to say this
has been a good season i i do think this
is a team that you're not ready to say
this is championship level just yet but
first of all look at their division i
know there are the unknowns because the
two bees and brown and bell are gone
from pittsburgh
but
do you think pittsburgh is completely
done not with roethlisberger not with
the i think the call to action that is
uh permeating throughout the building
right in pittsburgh we know what
baltimore's done through the years i
know they have maybe as much attrition
in the off-season as anyone
but we also know that the road to this
division has gone through those two
teams for a very very long time i'm not
ready to say the road goes through
cleveland so win nine in a division
where maybe ten will get it done this
year
uh then i think that's going to be a
successful season for the browns if they
keep building because they've got a lot
of young talent
mike you got great perspective on the
league i know you know people you got
great knowledge like what's the mic to
rico broad picture thing that you're
looking at for the 2019 nfl season that
kind of just jumps out to you what is it
anything you know interesting team
player well what is something that's
kind of been uh tickling your fancy
lately are we gonna move we'll move just
past the given of look the patriots have
this significant rise of change in some
key spots but they're gonna be fine yeah
and at some point they won't be but
we're like okay fine we all know that
we'll you know there'll be two and two
we'll be on football night the question
we guys what's wrong with the patriots
should we panic no they'll be fine um
i'm i'm really
truly interested in two teams one on
each side
kansas city
uh you know obviously kareem hunt not
there if tyrek hill is not there this
year yeah which every indication is that
that's going in that direction
what's the true impact on that offense
uh you know that look at those two guys
made a significant difference they
weren't the same after hunt was out of
the mix and obviously hill just think
about the fourth down plays that were
made during the year i think they're
most dynamic plays plays that flip the
field there aren't a lot of guys you can
go get who can do that so whether it was
through the draft or with other players
do they have that element still in their
offense and then the other one to me is
the rams i thought the rams were just on
this upward trajectory here for the last
couple of years and they got to the
super bowl
and they ran into
what they saw a little bit guys if you
think about it in a couple of games they
played late in the season starting with
a game they won the game at detroit
the rams offense started to struggle a
little bit so there's a little bit of a
book on them and that's i don't think
it's mcveigh i think it's going to come
down to jared goff i saw jared earlier
in this offseason he knows it he knows
he's got to take another step up and to
me that's going to be one of the
fascinating things because the rams had
the feel of a championship level team
last year now with some changes in free
agency
hitting this bump in the road a little
bit from an exo standpoint with goff can
he take that next growth step that is
natural for a quarterback at this point
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports